good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to be
your real self over to ukrs one of that
I'll say it again
like in a store you be you if you give
me your real okay you can never be
deceitful holding a life you it's very
successful
i 100% agree that you will only have
your real success when you find your
real self and you apply it and you take
action on it every single day you can
model you could copy and you could learn
from others to get somewhere faster but
you will never reach your true potential
by being a junior version of somebody
else
I had an entrepreneur a friend of mine
reach out to start a new business she
was one of the top trainers at a gym
here in Canada and she wanted to go
teach that training system to other
people basically take the train that she
learned for the big corporate and apply
it and help smaller gym through their
training using that model all she would
be at zest is the junior version of the
big corporate so somebody as an example
of studying under Tony Robbins and goes
out and applies his strategies to help
other people if you don't build on it if
you don't improve on it then all you're
going to be SS is a junior Tony Robbins
you're going to be a poor man Tony
Robbins so somebody can't afford Tony
they might come to you you could be so
much more than a junior version of
somebody else and so yes you model a new
copy and you learn to get ideas to test
to try to implement and then to tweak
and improve and make your own so as an
example when I was working with my agent
in my media trainer they would always
give me assignments every week they
would say Evan your next video you have
to do this try this try this give me
different assignments and Steve came at
it from a very aggressive you got to
raise the stakes you got to make it more
important point of view and Jamie came
at it from a more connection loving soft
point of view and it would always give
me assignments
every assignment they gave me never
quite hit always felt uncomfortable I
would do it I would do it like they
wanted me to do it and it never quite
fully connected it was a stretch it was
better than what was currently doing but
it wasn't quite what I needed and I
always had to take their advice and
tweak it a little bit and build on it
and grow it to make it feel right for me
and so every time you're learning these
strategies that I'm sharing on this
channel you're learning from Steve Jobs
or Oprah Winfrey or whoever it is you
look up to want to be a huge success
your goal should never be to be the next
Steve Jobs or Oprah Winfrey your goal is
to be the best version of yourself and
you do that by modeling others and
learning from them and then tweaking the
strategies so that it fits for you so
the question today today is I'm curious
what is one thing that you've learned
from somebody successful or somebody on
this channel and then tweak their
strategy to make it work in your
business leave it down the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Arielle Arielle thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book here one
word I really really appreciate it and I
hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
presto
or spray so give me go
you know one of the things I've learned
over time is that the best you'll ever
be if you're trying to be someone else
is a pale imitation you know most people
spend their whole life look at it you
know this I want to be like this person
I want to be like that person one of you
know
one of the things that I can't stand is
people you know all these celebrities
and people that want to be like them the
truth is you have to be the best you you
can be there's only one you I mean
there's not another one on the face of
the planet now you need to learn from
other people from some people you need
to learn what not to do from something a
lot of people you need to learn what to
do but as you study people as you look
at successful people study their trades
study their behavior study what they do
and then take the best and leave the
rest you have to create an authentic you
now does that mean you don't need to
learn from other people no but you've
got a step back and go well okay this
person is super outgoing in Fulop and
I'm not wired that way maybe I'm quieter
we are never going to be like them but
learn from them take the best and then
when you look at some other person
that's got a great skill set that maybe
doesn't line up with your skill set but
take and learn things that you can put
to work in your life but factor all of
that together by understanding who you
authentically are find what you're good
at all of us have a list of things that
we're good at but the truth is we spend
way too much way much more time working
on what we're bad at trying to get
better at it well I'm telling you the
thing that you're naturally bad at and
you can work all day long seven days a
week on it
and the best you'll ever be at that is
mediocre somebody is naturally good at
what you're bad at but I guarantee you
you have natural skills that were just
born in you a part of your DNA that
you're good at without even trying and
then other people are terrible at it I
mean I've always been able to speak in
front of people it's never bothered me
for a lot of people it mortifies them
it's never been a real problem and so
what I was able to do is find a way that
there was something I knew that I was
good at that I could show up without any
notes and do better than most people and
then work like crazy at it spend my time
focused on what I'm good at
see I believe each of us if we found our
natural inclinations and then we focused
on what we're good at you're going to be
the best you you can be
I believe great teams are made up of a
bunch of individuals who find a way to
mesh together in a way that accentuates
each person's positive for the good of
the group so be the best authentic you
you can be work on yourself focus on
yourself understand your strengths and
weaknesses and find ways to put yourself
in a place where your strengths are
magnified what do you want to say to
your fans that are asking like yo like
are you still going to make that high
bpm you know festival music - Lee are
you leaving that for more I'm not
leaving anything mainstreamer can you
explain that transition and what you're
doing that for me it's all about trying
to find new sounds reinventing your own
sound
I can I can I can release 128bpm clubs
on every every week but I don't know I
want to challenge myself to you I want
to try out new things on experiment and
me trying out something new and doing
something like scared to be lonely or
name of love doesn't mean completely
switching myself I
like in October I just released seven
like very aggressive 128bpm house/funk
and I've got ultra coming up after
Coachella coming up and I'm going to
also play a lot of old sounding more
indirect stuff if it's a weight
situation because then I release how
song one year going they're like oh
same rabbit repetative boring stuff and
try some do something new be refreshing
and I do something you only like we miss
the old Martin garrix you know like wait
what you guys want me to do but for me
what I think is most important is just
me being myself in the studio doing what
I want em don't let other people's
opinions affect my music I want to
represent what I want to make and I'm
not switching my sound I'm just having
fun you might think how many
archaeologists we nobody's looking no
each I can't comment on me I just exist
in that quiet space I realize I am
worthy by Earth I am fierce and fabulous
because I breathe all of us here in this
room we are worthy we compounded our
journey on real and worthwhile and
there's nothing and I want to do to take
a living on everything show that it
happened
we have a choice it helps to bring up a
lot of time or Ashley I imaging is the
fear of humiliation the fear of a few
impossible judgment in flash people will
judge you whether you throw a different
observe or tell me how much my role is
so I am a wife but not define me I am an
actress and I should help not define me
I'm a parent while all those at a
nominal life nonetheless same even
though I did a lot of praise that maybe
we'll tease I am worthy Ivor slit I am
Gabrielle usually